Okay,
so this is what we looked at last time.
We looked at an acid base
reaction from a new point of view,
from the point of view of bringing up
some homo to overlap with this unusually
low Lumo.
Why is it unusually low?
The Lumo sigma star of c of
h f why is it unusually low?
Is the overlap bad?
Does the hybrid orbital on fluorine
and the s orbital on hydrogen,
does that have bad overlap or is they
overlap? Well points right at it.
Good overlap. So that's not
the reason. It's unusual.
What's the reason that the energy of
this vacant orbit always unusual Dana?
Right? Cause blue rain started
very low, so that went down
well,
that mixed with hydrogen.
Hydrogen went up but didn't go up very
far because the energy match was bad.
So that's this Lumo the unfavorable,
a combination of fluorine and hydrogen,
which is at big on hydrogen or, yeah.
Fleury the one that
went up hydrogen, right?
The good one is mostly on
fluorine, the bad one. Sigma
Star, mostly on hydrogen.
And it has that node shown as an
anti-bonding node. Sigma Star.
The Star means anti-bonding.
So when Ooh minus with it's high energy
occupied orbital. Now wait a second.
Why is it unshared pair on oxygen?
High Energy.
I thought oxygen had a big nuclear charge,
which would make electron stable,
not have them be high.
Why is o h minus?
Hi. Oh Vena, do you
have an idea about that?
What is it about o h minus the unshared
pair that makes the electrons unusually
high in energy is it didn't matter.
It didn't matter cause it did
mixed with anything else, right?
It's not like a bond that went down.
We're comparing it to
c h r I s,
e c Sigma Bonds that wet down in energy.
So even though oxygen started low,
it didn't go down right?
So it's on your left,
unusually high.
And there's actually another reason
that this one is unusually high.
Josh.
Negative charge on oxygen doesn't
make electrons happy. Okay,
so let's tell them as long mixes with
that in the process of putting electrons
into that
orbital,
it makes the bond,
but also it makes it anti-bonding
between hydrogen and flooring.
So we draw that second curved Arrow
that shows the fluorine leaving with the
electrons that it already had.
Most of the electrons that leaves with,
not that you can really label
electrons and say, this one is this,
this one is this. But remember,
flurry mixed with hydrogen went down.
It already has most of those
electrons that came from hydrogen.
Now it has the mall. When it breaks
away, breaks away is that I am f minus.
Okay?
And that's an acid base reaction.
The more general interpretation of
base than just h plus reacting with Oah
minus. Okay? Now let's
generalize a little bit further.
So notice that besides
creating a new bond,
which would happen with h plus mixing
the homo with this Lumo can break a bond,
right? If the Lumo shown there
has an anti-bonding node,
putting in electrons means that those
electrons will be more stable if flurried
moves away, right? So, so you
can, to not only make a bond,
you also break a bond.
So it's a make and break situation,
whereas h plus plus o h minus
is just to make situation,
okay? Now let's look at FCH three, right?
And look at the orbital and I'm going
to super impose on it the corresponding
Lumo of f c h three watch it.
Change
the carbon carbon bond as long or the
carbon fluorine bond is longer than the
carbon hydrogen bond. So it
moved away, but the shape,
especially around the fluorine is almost
identical. I'll back up and do it.
Do the change again,
right?
So it's going to have very
similar properties to what HF did.
So if I move it over,
you see it's going to be attacked by
something coming here to overlap with that
orbital.
Some high homo will mix with the low
Lumo and here we show o h minus doing it,
and then what will happen?
Remember we have this
anti-bonding node here.
What happens when electrons
go into that orbital Katie?
Okay,
yeah.
The fluorine will take electrons
and move away like that, right?
So we get fluoride and methanol,
right?
And this reaction, which we'll study
at the beginning of next semester,
and we'll mention a little bit
more as we go along this semester,
but systematically we'll talk about
it next semester is called sn two
substitution.
But notice it's from the point of view
of orbitals exactly the same make and
break situation that you had
with Oah minus reacting with Hf.
It's the same reaction,
just the names have been changed,
right?
So you could in fact have
called the reaction of Ooh,
minus with Hf.
You could have called that a substitution.
It could have been sn two substitution.
The difference would be that the atom
on which the substitution takes place,
the one that gets attacked and then
loses the f minus is hydrogen rather than
carbon. So you could call
both reactions, substitution,
or you could call them both
acid base reactions. Right?
So that's the way science,
as I said last time,
progress by seeing generality,
right?
Where things were thought to be before.
Okay.
So we have these two reactions, acid
based reaction, sn, two substitution.
What would happen if
we had Ethel fluoride,
sometimes known as ethanol,
improperly properly labeled.
Right earlier today. Okay. So that's,
that's the Lumo of ethanol.
Now that doesn't look exactly like the
Lumo we just calculated of ethanol,
but it's, remember it was the Lube
oil plus three wasn't that it?
That we found is either plus two or plus
plus three wasn't that the Lumo plus
three remember,
had this characteristic that it's a
favorable mixture of two simple pairwise
orbitals.
That one is what?
What's that orbital if you just saw that
same thing, it's the same
thing that's up there, right?
It's sigma star
c h instead of CF
or w uh, uh, it's certainly a sigma star,
but it's an HC not of FC. Right?
Everybody got that? So it's,
but it's sigma star.
That's the important thing.
It's the anti-bonding combination.
Sigma Star C H.
Okay. And what's the other
thing that goes into this?
Lumo or actually the Lumo plus three.
It's this,
what's that?
All right,
Angela,
can you give it the name?
It's like
if you then just to Adam's what is that?
You speak up loudly. So everybody
from Sigma Star. So yeah,
everybody say that.
Oh Man.
And I say it's the favorable mixture of
these two because they're put together
so as to be bonding between them. Right?
So there were two vacant orbitals,
Sigma Star, CF and Sigma Star
C H. Right. And they mixed.
And the favorable combination where they
overlap favorably between those two is
the one we're looking at.
It's still vacant.
That's an unoccupied molecular orbital.
But that's the one we're looking at here.
Okay. Now, uh, how should it react? Well,
that one looks like the top right
except that the colors are changed,
right?
So how about doing sn two substitution
now Russell cringed when I
did that. What's wrong with
doing sn? Two substitution?
Yeah.
Aha.
What's hidden in here is that Bin,
it's going to be hard to overlap
with the blue on top without heavy,
an unfavorable overlap
with the red on the bottom.
So there's another way you could
do it. You could attack here, right?
And get a big orbital,
a big lobe all have the same sign.
So there you're going to get good overlap.
So might it do that?
So there are two possibilities that could
do the same as the topic could do sn
two substitution,
or it could put electrons into this
Lumo by attacking from this second Arrow
position.
And how do you know which one it does?
You do experiment. So this is
lore, right? And what we get to see
studying these reactions systematically,
you'll see that both things can happen.
They're both possibilities and
you can make little tweaks,
insolvent or based and things like that.
What Homo you're using.
That'll make it go a little more one
way or a little more of the other.
But that of course takes time to do all
the experiments and to hear about them.
But anyhow,
there are these two possibilities.
Now let's suppose it does the
second one, uh, now how do,
how did I set it up so that
that would be favorable?
I didn't use the true Lumo have
the lowest energy of the molecule,
which I just calculated for
you at the beginning of class.
What I did was used that Lumo plus three,
but made it the Lumo.
And the way I made it,
the Lumo was to stretch bonds.
I stretched the ch bond and
I stretched the CF bond,
right?
And then if I,
this particular phase of
vibration of the Adams,
this one is in fact the Lumo. Okay,
now why did I want to show you this?
Look what happens if you
do that bottom thing. Okay,
so we bring o h minus up and the electrons
go into this and make a bond between
h and no, but there's a note
here that anti-bonding node.
What does that mean?
If you put electrons into this
orbital Lexi, what are you saying?
It'll break where?
Between the hydrogen and the carbon.
Okay, so we're gonna, we'll draw
a second curved arrow that shows
those electrons pulling out.
Okay, now where do they go?
Look at the, here, there's
an atomic orbital node there.
That's not an anti bonding node because
it's the node of the p orbitals on the
carbons.
Everybody see that?
That's not anti-bonding because it
doesn't go between the atoms that goes
through the Adams.
So in fact,
if you look at that blue and red
lobe in the middle there a little bit
distorted.
But what do they look like
if you look just at the red and
blue in the middle of Lucas Dot. P
Greek.
It's the Pi orbital made up of two P
orbitals to p orical at the carpet on top
of p orbital department on the
bottom for electrons in that
got a double bond between the carbons.
Okay?
Okay, so there's a pie
bonding between the carbons.
That means we can draw a second Arrow
that takes the electrons out of the bond
that's breaking and puts them between
the two carbons to make a double bond.
Okay?
But now there's another node in this
Lumo there that anti-bonding node.
What happens with respect to that?
When we put electric
transit in this Lumo,
Rick, what are you saying?
The bond between CNF we'll break.
How will we draw curved Arrow shows
not starting at the seat,
which are the electrons that are leaving.
You started with the electrons
that are changing, right?
So where are they in this diagram here?
Here.
Tell me when to stop.
When I hit the lifestyle out here,
that's the one that's
building up electrons.
These are the electrons that are leaving
and where do I draw on the curved Arrow
to where are they going?
Okay. Onto the APP. So that's
what happens when the, Ooh,
that you get water,
you get ethylene,
the double bond and fluoride.
So this is called,
as you'll see just after we
talk about sn two substitution,
we'll talk about e to elimination,
right? And that's what this reaction is,
right? Uh, but that's just a cat. An old
category, right? If we want to make it,
what it is is the same kind
of Homo Lumo interaction.
Except this time we make two bonds and
break to bonds because of where the nodes
were in the Lumo that was being attacked,
right?
There were two anti-bonding nodes.
We break to bonds.
Okay?
Is anybody have a question about this
to see how it works? Lucas, why?
Why did I do it?
Because I knew the answer.
I knew that this reaction
does this eat to elimination.
Because when I studied organic chemistry,
we
did eat to elimination and never
talked about or bowls at all. Okay.
So I knew where I was going. I knew
what really happened. So I said,
how does that happen that this is the
orbital that actually gets attacked and
it's in fact the Lumo plus three, right?
Why do the electrons go into that?
And then I saw that in a certain
phase of vibration of the molecule,
when this bond is long and when this
bond is stretched than it is the Lumo.
So the, when the Oah is attacking,
the Oah minus is attacking,
it's attacking you at a time that those
bonds are stretched at the same time.
Right? And then they break, okay.
It's a little bit of chicken and the
egg as to whether the electrons going in
make them stretch or they're stretching
allows the electrons to go in.
Right? But at anyhow, that's,
I knew what the answer was,
which you wouldn't have known if you
had just looked at the orbitals for the
minimum energy geometry of the molecule.
Okay.
Now let's look at,
let's generalize this to a complicated,
are fairly complicated reactions scheme,
at least by our lights.
So three ammonia molecules
react with chlorine.
That's called oxidation of ammonia,
and it generates hydrazine
the nitrogen nitrogen bond,
or actually hydrazine IOM.
It's a cad I and chloride
and ammonium chloride.
That looks pretty complicated.
There's a lot of changes going on.
How does it happen? Could we figure
it out? I think you can. Okay.
So in the starting material, I want to
find a high homo. Where do I find it?
Sherwin, could you help
us? What do I love?
I want to find the high volume only
is starting with Geraldine Hunt,
starting Joe's or ammonia
and the chlorine molecule.
So what about them could give you a high,
unusually high occupied or goals?
Say, say clear. Yeah,
the unshared pair of ammonia.
Alright.
And has a bigger nuclear charge than c.
So you might expect the
electrons to be low in energy.
Never mixed with anything. So it
didn't go down to become a sigma bond.
So unshared, bear on, I
think that that's okay.
Now we have to react
that with some, uh, so,
and unshared payers are often denoted n
I actually the little n and I actually
don't know why that is. It'd
be fun to find out, okay,
now we need a low Lumo.
Anybody got an idea
for what a low Lumo might
be in the system? Yeah.
What kinds of things
give rise to low lumos
Sam electro negative
electronegative nuclei, right?
Big nuclear charges. You know,
people always say electronegative,
but that's the cart and the horse.
Why is something electronegative that
means it's a good place for electrons to
go because right.
It's because the nuclear charge is big.
That's what's fundamental. Okay. Where
do we find that here in the chlorine,
the chlorine now,
which orbital associated with the
chlorine is going to be unusually low in
energy. Does it have a, does it
have a vape at the atomic orbital
in mind? What's called chlorine
is in the last column, right?
So it just missing one electron.
So a chlorine atom has three
unshared pairs and one odd electron,
which is common with the other
chlorine to make that bond. Right?
So after the cl two forms,
where's the vacant orbital?
Anybody see
we had two chlorine's each with this,
with this odd electron.
They came together and
you got a sigma bond.
Where's the low Lumo Chris?
No,
six Sigma Star,
right? They each had one electron
come together. They went down,
but there was a sigma star that went up.
Sig Sigma Stars.
Really high energy, but not in this
case because of Sam pointed out the,
the nuclear charge is big, so it's
low. So Sigma Star on chlorine.
Okay.
So what kind of reaction
are we going to have
if we mixed sigma star of glory
with the unshared pair on nitrogen?
Have you ever seen a
reaction like this before?
Where are you at the Sigma Star
mixing with an unshared pair.
Kaitlin,
on the last slide we saw lots of
examples, right? And so Katelyn,
what happens will tell me how
to draw curved Arrow here.
Okay.
Electrons on the untrimmed bear
nitrogen. That's the high home. Well,
between one,
between the nitrogen and the chlorine.
They mixed with that vacant ornamental,
but the ones that the glory,
now that's an empty bonding.
Orbitals sigma star. So a chloride
leaves. So it's exactly the same reaction,
make and break that we saw before.
Okay. There. So we get, uh,
ammonium chloride and cl
minus plus minus net neutral.
We started neutral. We're still neutral.
Okay. And now we have one of the products,
the chloride up above we have.
Okay.
But we also have this molecule.
Now it has a low Lumo,
so it's reactive.
What is the low Lumo?
That's not what I would've said.
Turns out to be right,
but it's not what I would've said
they're going to be.
Nah,
it's gotta be vacant.
So what's the name of the
orbital Sigma Star? Nh.
Are there any other Sigma Stars here?
Russell cl,
which is,
which is going to be lower sigma
star in cl or Sigma Star and age.
I would add too.
So the most like the
lowest flew mo is for that,
for some homo.
Now what are we gonna use for a homo?
We have to have another reagent
for this to react with. Well,
fortunately that sigma star and h
is what we're actually going to use.
Okay.
It's the high homo.
We had three ammonias to begin with so
we can use another one. Same deal again.
Right?
So the best reaction I think would be
for the unshared pair to attack the
chlorine. At least that's something that
you could imagine. If that happened,
what would the product be
if Nh three attack cl,
it would make an Nh three
cl bond and lose one.
What? Russell. So what about this?
It could happen till the cows come home,
but the product is the same as the
starting material and no one cares.
It would exchange
which, which caloric, which nitrogen
is attached to the chlorine.
But unless you label them
with isotopes or something,
you'd have no way of knowing.
So that,
that probably does happen or at least
that I suspect that happened some of the
time. Right. But you don't care.
So now we resort to une Jews suggestion
that we'll use a different one.
So we get a different product.
Okay. So we'll attack the,
the Nh bond. Now, uh, uh, Corey,
tell us how
draw curved Arrow to show this.
Where's the curved Arrow going to start
on the lone pair? The nitrogen.
And where will it end in between?
In between the end of the age
and what else will happen?
Which one? What's going to take
off with the electrons? Can you see
nothing? Well, that is what you Lou,
it becomes an unshaded pair on nitrogen.
Dan was in plus right now he gets the
electrons that formerly it was sharing
with age. So it ends on
nitrogen, right? So there's the
product and now I've highlighted in blue
another one of the ultimate products,
right?
So now we've made ammonium chloride,
We've made one of the products,
but we need the other,
but we have this product
from the second reaction.
Now what do we have for a low Lumo here?
Maybe you have an idea.
You have only sigma bonds at an unshare
fair on nitrogen and three unshared
fairs on Flory, right? No,
but those were all occupied.
What's a vacant on?
But I'll hear what kind of vacant orbitals
you get in molecules that have only
sigma bonds. [inaudible] no,
the p roles are filled with electronics
here, right? So they're not vacant.
Sigma Star.
Which segments you have to sit in each
sigma star and you have the sigma star.
Which one do you think it's lower?
No, it wasn't the one that
reacted last time was the Nh,
but it wasn't the lowest. The MCL was
the lowest. Why? We're quite ever,
we care last time because
the product one that reacted,
you got the starting material
back. So the care. All right,
so this time it's the MCL.
Alright, what's the hot high
Hobo we're going to use?
Ah, Wilson. Oh, we got a third one that
will bring it in and they're
the curve there owns,
there's the product
hydrazine high resilience.
It's got a proton and as a plus
charge. Hi Laura. Hi Laura.
All right, so that is the last
product. So we've done it.
So there are three of these
reactions that take place.
Three cycles of Macon break and
notice the difference among them,
right?
It's always Nh three that attacks,
but first that a tax chlorine,
none of the tax hydrogen
then at the tax nitrogen.
But it's the same reaction we talked
about on the previous slide. Right?
Making break. Okay. Now we're going
to look at for functional groups,
the c double bond o carbon eel amid
carboxylic acid and Al Lithium.
And after that we'll have done what we
wanted to do about functional groups,
although it will still be in your court
to do functional groups because you have
these wikis to do the same
kind of analysis on the
functional groups that we're
doing here on these four functional groups
and those are due Thursday and almost
all of them are signed up for,
they're just a few more to do.
So if you want a choice,
get there quickly cause I'll assign them
this afternoon I think because we're
almost at the end and I have to
make sure everything gets covered.
Okay, so the Carbondale
group, c o double bond.
This is probably the most important
functional group in organic chemistry.
Why is it so important?
A, because it strong,
so it gives stable compounds,
low energy compounds.
So you have a lot of Carbondale groups,
but paradoxically it's not only
strong but it reacts easily.
So it's easy to make things
from carbon eels. Okay.
That sounds contradictory, that it
should be both stable and reactive,
but it is. And we'll see why. So let's
look at the shape of the frontier.
Orbitals there six valence
electron pairs in the, uh,
in formaldehyde shown here from the side.
And we could show the molecular orbitals,
right?
The Claude knees style plum pudding,
molecular orbitals.
So the lowest,
uh,
so the lowest one is one s or two
s if you want to count the core,
right, which is at, which is mostly
on the oxygen, a little bit on carbon.
And then there's a two Px, two
p y n two P, Z as plum pudding,
orbitals. And then there's this
three s orbital and this three d x,
y orbital. But let's look a
little more closely at that. Uh,
from the point of view
of Pairwise Interactions,
what things interacted with
one another to give these,
so let's do the kinds of pairwise
mixing we've been talking about.
There's the Homo [inaudible],
an older style picture of the Homo,
the one that's called
three d, x, y on the right.
And this is drawn at a w was based on a
different calculation and it's drawn a
different contour level, but you
can see what it, what is it? Mostly
the whole bone.
If you had to give a simple name to it,
what would you call him?
If you have neglected the
little tiny pieces on the right,
what does the look like,
chairman?
It's a p orbital on oxygen and
unshared Parabox which is mostly,
although it is mixed a little
bit with something else.
Now to see what else it's mixed with.
We can go down the list by
three steps and look at that. Or
the one that's called two p y because
it also has that little bit of oxygen in
it,
but more of the other stuff.
Now let's look at nodes in these things.
There's nodes that are nodes of atomic
orbitals of the oxygen and the carbon.
They bisect the molecule. Those
don't have to do with bonding, right?
But the one on the top also
has an anti bonding node.
Can you see where that is?
Shy,
maybe between the carbon and
the oxygen is anti-bonding node.
So this is a favorable
and
an unfavorable combination
of in the front oxygen,
the front left his oxygen and in the
back right as some sort of ch bond.
So we're those molecular orbitals are
made by combining two p of oxygen with
Sigma Chi.
In fact,
two Sigma Chi is okay now,
which one is lower in energy?
The unshared pair on oxygen or Sigma Chi.
Notice that the oxygen has something going
for it, which is a big nuclear charge,
but the CHS has something going for it,
which is the bonding of the CH,
which lowered it from where carbon
and hydrogen atomic organism,
which one is lower?
The two P of oxygen or Sigma Chi,
which wins.
Can you tell by looking at this
and all
the favorable combination,
which looks mostly like the lower one
looks mostly like Cah and the unfavorable
one, the one that went up looks
mostly like, oh, so clearly the
Sigma Chi is lower in energy
than the two P of oxygen. Okay.
Now let's look at the Lumo up on top
and the plum pudding column, right?
And here's another version of that,
and you can see what it is.
It's made up of a p orbital on
oxygen and a p orbital on carbon.
Those are atomic orbital.
That's an atomic orbital node has
nothing to do with the bonding,
but there is an anti-bonding
node between them, right?
So this is the Pi star orbital,
not the occupied one,
but the vacant orbital, the Lumo, right.
There's poor overlap because as Pi Star,
that's why it's unusually low and it's
also unusually low compared to see cc
because it's got an oxygen
in it high nuclear charge.
So poor energy match to Po is lower
in energy than the two P of carbon.
Okay? And there, we're going to show
this on the next slide, those two.
But the top one you see is the favorable
combination of two po and to peasy the
one of which this is the unfavorable
combination, but it's not the homo,
right? The homo is that unshared
pair on, on, uh, oxygen,
which is the dominant
thing in three d x y. Okay,
so now let's look at these. There's
the CEO, Pi bonding or bundle.
Now, which one should that
be big on? Don't look at it.
Which one should it be?
The Pi,
the favorable combination of
pee on oxygen and fee on carbon,
which should it be big on?
There's pee on oxygen,
P on carbon.
They mixed pie overlap.
Not Too much overlap so they
don't get so much up and down.
But what does this most of the bonding,
the bonding would,
what does it mostly look like?
Should look mostly like oxygen.
When you're looking at this picture,
it doesn't look
that way.
That's because of which contour tour we
drew because oxygen holds its electrons
closer, so by the time you get
out to a certain low you you,
so you get through the most
of the electron density of
oxygen as you go out one
contour by the other of the onion.
That's the oxygen it.
They're more electrons inside.
So indeed it does have more electron
density on oxygen than it does on carbon,
but it doesn't show well in
this particular contour. Anyhow,
that's the pie bonding,
and this one is an unsafe,
a different unshared pair on oxygen.
That's mostly a p rich hybrid,
atomic orbital of oxygen,
but it's got a little bit of the ch
bonding and it's a favorable combination.
There's a little bit of favorable
bonding between there. Okay, and but,
but the nodes that you see in this,
it neither orbital are
the nodes anti-bonding.
They're always the nodes that go through
Adam's. They're part of atomic orbitals.
These are bonding orbitals, the
occupied winds as you expect them to be.
Okay, but now let's look at that Lumo,
that vacant orbital, the Pi Star orbital.
What direction should a high energy homo
approach this in order to mix with it?
So it has to get good overlap as it comes
in and not run into the other nuclei
or the other electron density associated
with other oracles on the way yet.
Okay, well, here are three
possibilities. You could have
attack from within the plane,
from the oxygen end,
from within the plane toward the carbon,
or from straight up the halfway
between carbon and oxygen.
How do those look as ways for an
orbital to come in and overlap?
Suppose it came from the right.
Suppose you had a big ball like Ooh,
minus coming in along
that Arrow from the right,
you're going to get good overlap.
What would you call that situation?
Orthogonal.
Right? So you're not going to get over.
How about the left? The Arrow on the left,
that's also going to be orthogonal.
How about if you come from the top?
It's not precisely orthogonal,
but it's pretty close to her thought and
all you have both positive and negative
overlap. So in fact,
none of those are good.
Now here are two other possibilities.
You could attack the oxygen
or on the top or you could
attack the carbon on the top.
Which of those do you think looks better?
Carbon wire on Jolen cause it's bigger.
Okay,
so I'd say that one smaller. So forget
that. So come in from the car and then,
okay,
so here's a better drawing of that orbital
and we want to come in actually from
that direction at a certain angle,
not 90 degrees.
With respect to the oxygen carbon bond.
Now,
why come in from that angle?
Why not come straight down on top?
There are the nodes, right?
This is furthest from the node.
So you can overlap the load you want to
overlap with without getting near the
blue ones. I'd say you shouldn't
come into the certain angle.
Now there's a prediction.
Is it true?
So what we're going to do is rotate this.
So the orientation
corresponds to a graph
that appeared in a paper,
uh,
buy donuts and Borghi in 1983
when they were analyzing this,
now what did they do? They looked at
ex-ray crystal structures of many,
many crystals that had
both a nitrogen in it.
So the unshared pair,
and they had a carbon oxygen double
bond and they looked to see in many,
many different structures how those
atoms are arranged because they must be
arranged in a low energy way
next to one another. Okay?
That's the way they would
pack it in the crystal. Okay,
so now how's this diagram made?
Well,
notice that the carbon and
oxygen are drawn there.
So that's the carbon and
oxygen and they're made.
So all these different crystals,
some have the group oriented this way,
some this way,
so this way some this way.
So you rotate all those crystals so that
their carbons are super imposed with
one another and all the structures,
the carbons are all there and the
oxygen is along this particular line,
which lies in the plane of the screen.
Right?
And then there are things attached to it,
which are our groups and our,
our group too,
that vis whatever group, hydrogen or
carbon or something attached to the,
to the carbon. There's one in front of
the plane and one behind the plane. Okay.
So we rotate all of these different
structures around that carbon oxygen bond.
So those things are all one,
Heidi and the other one,
the R in front hides the are behind.
And now we look with that orientation
to see where the nitrogen is nearby and
those dots up on the top show in many
different structures labeled a, B,
c, d, e, f, g, H, I, j, k, l. Okay.
In all those different structures.
Where's the nitrogen? So in structure, uh,
g of particular compound,
the nitrogen is where the blue.is on top.
The carbon is all,
all the carbons are always there.
That's the origin right here.
The oxygens are along this line.
So the oxygen's along that
line and at that position,
that distance and the art groups are
bent down a little bit from being,
one is here and the other one is behind.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. But now look, let's go. G, h.
I.
J. K. L. G. H. Hi.
Hey.
Hello.
Do you see what happens?
Let's go back.
Okay.
I h.
G these are five different
crystal structures. Look again.
So the nitrogen comes down
from one structure to the next.
What happens to the RS
as the night as the night comes down,
right? The RS bend down. So the
nitrogen, the carbon, pardon me,
in the middle becomes a pyramidal
rather than planer. Back Up.
What happens to the oxygen as we do this?
There's g
H. Okay, now.
All right. Okay. So here's what
happened. The nitrogen moves down,
the RS bend down and the oxygen away.
Why does the oxygen move
away from the carbon?
From a theoretical orbital point of view,
where are you putting electrons?
Where are you putting the electrons here?
When you put them into this Lumo
into an orbital, that's Auntie
bonding between carbon and oxygen.
So the oxygen stretches away from
the car nowadays on the screen,
the units,
what does that that's on?
So it's zero is the origin.
That's where the carbon is.
And there's one offs from 1.0 2.0 3.0
so they start three the nitrogen starts
three on the carbon and comes in and
gets to be within about 1.6 or something.
And I forget my,
I'm guessing that that could an actual
bond between that nitrogen Carmen's
probably the order of 1.3 or something.
I'm not actually sure it is.
So they haven't quite bonded,
but it's following the pathway
of reaction when you look at a
lot of these different structures.
Okay.
Now that angle a 110 degrees,
the along the path that they follow
is called the Borges Danette's angle.
That's the guys who did the paper hotspot.
Bergie and Jack Donaldson in Switzerland.
So,
so there is a,
a bunch of what we might
consider snapshots of a
reaction actually taking place.
And you can see that there's a well
defined angle from which the nitrogen
approaches that Lulo as it mixes with it.
No resonance is in trauma,
like Eular,
Homo Lumo mixing. We've looked here
at intermolecular, which is reaction.
But next time we'll go onto this slide
and look at the analogous thing that
happens within a molecule.
Okay.